Ngoài phòng tỉnh lào cai vừa vừa vừa vừa, và các quân chức năng đấu tranh thành công.
Chua nán chịt phá đường dây vận truyền trái phép, kiếm lạc vi hiểm tự chung cút vào Việt Nam.
Thu dữ 2,3 phẩm mộn kí lâu gà bạc tinh kiet.
Chiu ngày 1,3 bẩy, tại khu vực lối vào cao tất nội bài lào cai.
Tổ con tác kiểm tra sê đầu kéo diện kiểm soát, hát, bà không sảo tảm mộn.
Dò lựu nình chỉ xin năm 18,5 trủ tại lào cai điều khiển.
Tên xe chở theo dưu tân vũ, xin năm 18,5 trủ cốc.
Lựa lượng trưng nào phát hiện và thù rữ mười lắm khu chương loại ghi là bạc.
Qua giám định toàn bộ tăng vật là bạc tinh kiet, đối tượng dưu tân vũ khai nhận vật truyền thời xô bát trên cho bông người Việt Nam với tả 2 mùa nghe dân tệ 1 kí lâu gà.
Mời gặp điều tra, bán chương án đã trợ tập nắm đối tự liên cua lần người Việt Nam để tiếp tục làm gió hành vi bước lộ tình vi.
Chào dụt mặt trong hàng nước giản, nhằm có mặt lực lượng kìm chá tại cơ hộ quốc tế sôn hai kìm không.